and hari krishna and they're already
started here david they have already
started uh we're only a few moves deep
but it is the spanish opening the roy
lopez that is signified by white's light
square bishop coming out early white
slight square bishop now on the edge of
the board pinning uh the black knight
actually just trading itself off now for
the black knight and
you can tell eric he's going to be
devastated by that last loss he was in
charge against pregnant
look at his face hands and hands on his
head now he's still remembering the
ghosts of that defeat and it was a tough
one
this looks a lot like hanson of the
masters tournament just some weeks ago
and and when he gets into these funks it
it transpires into his games as well
doesn't it simon yeah i mean it's
tilting
again something in poker which happens
far too often when i play um and
magnus is
really good at this magnus he loses the
game he nearly always bounce back and
win but
it's that psychological thing you lose a
game but you shouldn't have lost you
think about it too much you've got to
get out your head if you don't it will
affect your next play and i i i hope
eric's capable of uh forgetting that
game and bouncing back here
yeah he needs to but he is quite good
with the white pieces especially in the
opening uh we talked about this a bit
yesterday everything's pretty much
mapped out he knows his opening
repertoire inside out he's been playing
the same opening since he was seven
eight years old so he knows uh
everything pretty much up to move 10 15
20.
uh so it's i think it's a good thing for
him after bouncing back from a tough
tough loss that uh he'll be able to just
get his pieces out get a solid position
this pawn push just uh controlling some
squares stopping black slide squad
bishop from coming out and
also i think style wise it's quite nice
that he's playing someone against harry
krishna who loves his end games loves
his longer games
eric will get a bit of time to kind of
warm up get back into this one get over
the emotions of the previous defeat
meanwhile both sides have castled their
kings developing their pieces and with
this last pawn push it looks like eric
he's getting ready to throw pawns
forward in the center maybe just trying
to trade some stuff off trying to kind
of clarify the situation black has the
two bishops but black's pawn structure
not ideal for now very very balanced
opening yeah i mean
i hope we get a chess ball course from
eric as well at some point i mean i
think he'd do a brilliant course on how
to play one e4 because you mentioned
he's played this all his life and uh he
he's very dangerous of it and i know
harry krishna
has also done at least one course i know
he's done one on how to beat the french
defense um i think he's maybe even done
another end game course but um harry
krishna not much has been mentioned
about him really nice chat done some
commentary of him before and he really
understands chess he's he's uh a really
good positional player and in the ending
he he's up there with magnus carson has
about you know being one of the best
in-game players in the world
and we see now both sides maneuvering
their knights around here uh do you
think we're going to see something
really ambitious from harry krishna now
the black knight has just retreated and
yeah to me that always signifies uh
ivanka thinks yes uh to me that always
signifies in the current position that
black is about to pump forward throw
forward his f pawn just to open up a
line for his rook and if he does this
then the center will explode it's just
about whether black's pieces are ready
normally this signifies a kingside
attack for black very key game actually
isn't it this one if you look at the
standings harry krishna is in just about
in um qualification place in eighth
place let's remember half the field go
through after tomorrow and uh eric yes
he lost but if he bounces back with a
win here he's still got a great chance
of qualifying so you can see them eighth
and ninth what a big match for that
qualification this this this could
really you know turn things so um so i
think harry krishna
his the way he's gonna be thinking he's
probably thinking i know this sounds a
bit cruel but i'm playing one of the
lower rated players yes i've got black
but this is a guy i should beat so he
might take risks and he's also in ninth
place as well eric that's right
you know it's basically a key rifle yeah
okay key gain and football they call
this a six pointer so for example if
harry krishna wins he'll be four points
ahead of eric
pretty much clear of him but if hare
krishna loses he'll be two points behind
eric so there's a six point swing and uh
yeah crucial for the standings okay not
throwing forward that black f pawn
slightly disappointing that we would
have seen fire on the board there but uh
very logical harry krishna first just
developing black light squad bishop
and now the white knight heading to a
decent square actually this white knight
quite often in this pawn structure wants
to go to the edge of the board it's it's
kind of counter-intuitive we normally
say knights on the rim are dim or grim
but uh the white knight wants to park
itself on the a5 square in front of
black's isolated pawn there uh just
going towards the light squad bishop
white would love to trade off one of his
knights for one of the black bishops
right now but eric shaking his head
he's still remembering the last game
he's got to get it out i mean how do you
do that though digs i i this is bigger
i've got a very emotional player and um
you know i lose the game i think about
it far too much i mean
any advice you've anchored or david how
you can just forget about it
yeah you know i have some advice but you
know
it kind of depends on your personality
um what i try to do is i try to kind of
meditate it out
and just give myself like 10 minutes and
then just kind of figure out what is the
story i'm telling myself you know why am
i feeling like this and then afterwards
put it away but then i can i know that
some people don't feel that they have
this rage and it just you know i get the
rage i normally do well i used to just
get smashed
basically i found that was quite a good
way to forget about it don't do that
anymore but david i mean yourself i mean
you you i mean i used to be very very
emotional there were some trashed hotel
rooms and uh the like but i think just a
few years ago when i was uh maybe in my
20s i realized actually
it's you've got to get a balance of
caring not caring and
i just try and completely turn off my
mind meanwhile i do feel eric
unfortunately he is tilting and he's
just playing too fast at this early
stage it's already critical for white
look at the black pawn structure in the
center black's pawns are all flying
forward and
eric it's uncharacteristic for him to
play so quickly first of all normally he
needs his longer thinks just to feel out
the position to calculate a bit but uh i
mean second and most important
i just think he's skipping past the
critical moments position is about to
open up in favorable ways for black and
already we talked about this black f
pawn pushing forward not only has he got
that but the position is about to come
up uh become
uh perfect for this unrivaled light
square bishop and okay after this porn
trade i'm expecting something that you
highlighted earlier simon but with
colours reversed the black queen to come
across this is very typical i think i've
had virtually this exact maneuver before
in my own games the black queen is going
to come out look at the white king but
not just that
i don't really know what white is doing
if white ever trades pawns here you're
only helping black get rid of the double
pawns and there's so much pressure
against this central pawn here
it's got the two bishops it's the open
line for black it's the queen coming to
attack the white king it's all about
black right now it's just been a dream
opening and harry krishna has actually
played that move the most natural move
in the position the queen's coming in
and
eric's in big trouble already
yeah i don't like it at all
yeah it's like such a beautiful position
for hari krishna and eric in serious
trouble and he needs to just think
things through and try to do some
patchwork but whilst we're waiting for
eric to come up with a solution i do
have to share with you
a really cool selfie that we got from
robin of the hood and we love receiving
selfies always remember to take them in
landscape mode but get this
they are watching our
show
and they're thanking us because it helps
distract them from the pain of doing a
chess tattoo
on a tropical island in indonesia
a chest that's i mean isn't it so yeah
just take a look at that tattoo it's so
cool oh i love it robin off the hood and
uh yeah i want to see a softer picture
of the touch yeah well definitely tweet
us tweet us the after picture because
that is really really nice and uh yeah
you're welcome and we're so glad that
we're distracting you from the pain
maybe we need to see some chess tattoos
if anyone's got any out there i know uh
we have a friend over in gibraltar craig
who's got many chess tattoos he's got
he's got a pawn all across his hand
there um big big chest pawn but i'd love
to see some chess tattoos he's got a
tattoo of uh the name of your website
simon
on his bottom yes thanks david
let's not go into that night it was a
long story so
talky british championships yeah yeah no
bets involved whatsoever right any chat
any of the top chess players have any
chess pieces tattooed because often you
know when you see the olympians they all
have the five circles tattooed yeah
actually it's uh it's a common question
that comes up when we're just hanging
out with chess players
i mean i've struggled to name any chess
player inside the top 100 200 in the
world with a tattoo any any tattoo um i
don't know what it is maybe chess
players i'm thinking about i'm very
tempted just to become the first but
i've got what i've got a tattoo but i
i'm not in the top hundred or two
hundred so i'm a long way off do you
have a chest tattoo i don't have a chest
tattoo no no maybe one day i'll be
tempted you know so
any tattoos no tattoos no tattoos okay
you've anchored you would you be tempted
no not at all i'm too fickle person you
know i get really bored
too much of a commitment we're thinking
too long term chess players we're
wondering what it will look like in
30 40 years
yeah it's actually the reason
why i haven't got it because i'm like i
might not like it in five years yeah
it's true we get lasered off can't you
we'll just get a bigger one over the top
you know yeah get bigger and bigger no
but yeah i'd love to see some chess
tattoos anyway if anyone's got them
on twitter meanwhile i'm looking at the
current evaluation now it's it's saying
that tariq krishna is starting to
to also take a computer grip in addition
to having the more human grip on this
game and do you do you value it about
the same way as computer right now yes
unfortunately for eric i completely
agree we were talking about the human
aspect where black had very simple plans
the better pieces um the kind of logical
easy smooth way to start an attack
black's queen is about to come out as we
indicated a few moments ago
and
the computer's showing that those plans
are still about to happen but eric
hasn't really found a way to fight
against them
this rook move
what does it do simply yes i understand
that this white rook might end up on an
open file but everything on this white
on this b file is protected um so what
is this white rook doing i think there
are other priorities and once the black
queen joins the party
once the black queen comes out i'm
expecting the g6 square looking down at
the white king white pawn in the middle
of the board the e4 pawn
loose it's all turning against white
i just wanted to point out one thing
because i'm i'm looking we were showing
it earlier here just the standings but i
just wanted to point out that right now
the difference between eighth and
fifteenth
eighth and fifteenth is only three
points it's one win
even arientari who's now in 15th is in
the running of getting up there
that makes it interesting to follow the
others i recommend if you want to follow
the other games as well you can also go
to chess 24 and get an evaluation there
for the different ones because it's it's
really exciting right now look at this
with hari krishna at 12.
arientari at nine everyone's pretty much
got a chance then right i mean obviously
gwen a little bit out of it
unfortunately but that's that's that's
incredible you know someone gets a roll
of wins they they can qualify i was
trying to introduce the term moving day
for day three to you david right now you
can see what i'm talking about it's
definitely moving there
i mean look at all the arrows as well
the green arrows the red arrows the
players have been swapping places left
right and center um yeah i mean what an
exciting few days it's all about now who
can string together a couple of wins in
a row i mean if as you mentioned in 15th
place if aryan terry wins two games in a
row he's probably
right up there so
yeah hopefully an exciting photo finish
for tomorrow in the prelims but
meanwhile one move from uh harry krishna
and he's just retreated black slide
squad bishop so
maybe not the most incisive move not the
most direct move black just keeping his
bishop nice and safe and uh yeah if
harry krishna wins this one he's got to
be of one of the favorites to qualify
um he's got that kind of style as well
it's so hard to beat harry krishna he's
so solid
yeah he's sort of he's one of those
players you say just understands the
game um you know where the piece is
going he knows where the piece goes he's
very experienced he's been playing you
know a lot longer than eric in in
tournaments over the board everywhere uh
he's uh yeah got a good chess education
and
he'd be very happy uh with this position
i mean it's still you know he has got a
nice position but there is a thing
turning a nice position into a win and i
think that's a trouble that a lot of
players have they get a nice position
but at some point you've got to pull the
trigger you've got to you've got to do
something very dynamic often
and
you know it is nice but how does he
actually uh convert i mean after
bringing his queen out for example does
he just sort of wait um let's say eric
if eric can remain patient himself maybe
with like a3 david um yes you bring the
queen out here let's say white defends
with queenie two maybe i don't know if
that's the best move
where's the
you you have to do something a bit
aggressive at some point here don't you
at some point and i think that's what
eric needs to do he needs to force hare
krishna to pull the trigger at some
point put the pressure on him to uh be
accurate but the problem is in this type
of position i don't think black needs to
be accurate i don't see what white is
doing simply so for example as black i
would be tempted to just shuffle the
black king into safety in the corner at
some point when the moment's right you
bring the black knight i don't think yet
but you bring the black knight in to
attack the central pawn
the reason i say don't do this yet is
because maybe white's knight can come to
the edge of the board and annoy the
black queen
that being said maybe the black queen
could just capture a pawn in the center
i mean everything just looks so good for
black
yeah if i just throw the question back
at white what are you doing and this is
what i like to do in chess in general if
your opponent is doing nothing just
improve your pieces tuck the king away
to bed and say
what's your next move and
it's not easy as you mentioned simon
this pawn is the weakness the queen and
rook now
the two white two white best pieces are
tied down protecting a mere pawn that's
never a good sign and actually eric's
done that instantly in the current
position he's brought his queen forward
so now both of these pieces tied down
just to a mere pawn
yeah here harry krishna for sure at some
point he's going to bring his queen out
for some point he's going to tuck his
king away and okay first he trades a set
of pawns slightly surprising to me i
don't think he needed to rush maybe he
can move his knight now though i guess
is that the point uh before the knight
was kind of defending i don't know if he
moves it straight away but this might be
the logic behind it at some point later
he can move his knight in now
yeah i'm just slightly surprised to see
uh for example now if black does take
too much time at least the white rook is
going to get some targets uh suddenly
lines have opened up slightly and when i
have the two bishops i just want to
stabilize as long as possible so in this
position i would just want to maintain
the status quo
normally it's the side who is fighting
against the bishop player who needs to
accelerate the play he needs to open up
talking about accelerating the play you
know harry kushner's
gone for gold directly you know he
simply attacked the pawn i mean can you
can you go can eric play a very
aggressive night move here i was
thinking yeah i mean that kind of looks
logical you find correct i mean uh you
you want to change the pace of the play
because you're defending can you now
throw the white knight towards the king
i think it's both our first faults right
just to show your idea here simon this
is uh under attack now this pawn so you
can defend it with your knight but also
try and go on the attack trying to jump
in
uh to this square maybe into white and
to the black camp hitting this rook
getting complicated i think you're right
eric has to try something like this
because what else if you don't jump in
with your knight go on the attack then
you're reduced to passive moves maybe
this one just defending your pawn but
it just feels ugly yep this night jump
we want to see it
that's maybe what eric has to go for low
on the clock as well now
yeah uh eight eight and a half minutes
to uh harry krishna's 11.
okay he does he doesn't play that he
instead he just uh moves the queen yeah
i mean this one is understandable um
just defending everything now the white
rook at the bottom of the board defends
the central pawn
everything's holding together for now
for eric but aaron krishna he can build
up this pressure he can move that black
king i just want to get it into the
corner the black king's slightly
vulnerable on a diagonal so why not hide
out the corner the black queen will come
out
the problem for harry krishna here too
many good moves too many options
too many choices and uh he's played
quite quick up to this point hare
krishna but
yeah that's the dilemma that's when i
slow down when my position is too nice
and i'm like i don't want to spoil it i
don't want to touch anything it's all
too perfect
yeah i mean i i i i'm with you there
it's actually it's quite annoying
changing a beautiful position into a
concrete kind of uh position and i think
that's that is the problem that black
has though it is a nice position and
it's still like you have to do something
else here to to uh to you know get a
substantial advantage moving the queen
out as you say david maybe you can get
hit by the white knight uh could you
maybe move the queen all the way out i
mean that that's a useful move to play
uh getting it nearer to the the white
king uh something like that but it's
it's it doesn't look totally clear to me
at all yeah okay i can see black's got
two bishops but
i i white's gonna get counter play with
that open file that you mentioned david
very soon so it's not it's not totally
clear i feel yeah i i mean i still love
black's position i think it's fantastic
but maybe it could have been even better
um i do think suddenly the white queen
is on a better square than she
previously stood on black's knight i
understand why harry krishna put it
there but it was just a one move threat
i think this is a common mistake that
players make at all levels especially
when they're first starting the game is
they often make just one move threats
that actually if they're opponent guards
against successfully
it worsens their position uh sometimes
you have to think a bit deeper you can't
just attack with one piece and when your
opponent says no then
get stuck for ideas you have to
kind of build up as part of a longer
term plan
so uh that's what harry krishna is
trying to formulate right now and okay
part of the longer term plan maybe was
to bring the knight towards the white
king
and uh here it goes also opening up the
black brook on the f8 square which i
quite like
yeah so attacking chances definitely and
you know we always like it when a knight
appears on the f4 square
aggressive intentions
spice of life
i feel bad though fair cans he's
probably the happiest guy you find
outside of his chess games and then you
look at him playing these games here and
he looks utterly completely depressed
yeah yeah that's the suffering
that's that's a quote that's been used
many a time isn't it chess is suffering
simply you know don't need to add
anything else on to that but
it's it is
really hard to explain the emotions of
chess to a non-chess player i know a lot
of people have had relationships of
people who don't play chess and they
lose the game and you know their
girlfriend and boyfriend be like why are
you so miserable you know and it's and
it's really hard to sort of just explain
to them how much it means yeah it's just
yeah that's it that's the worst thing to
say
you know your partner or someone says
why are you so miserable it's only a
game and it's like it's my it's my life
it's everything you know it's like yeah
no so
it is it's incredible to me the worst is
there
there
you know you're still a great chess
player
i was just like oh no do they give you a
little pat when they're doing it as well
you know like on the head yeah
no but i actually i've actually tried to
control that part of my uh my chest
being because i thought you know it's
actually not my partner's job and i
don't think any chess partner's job to
actually sit there and try to cheer them
up i think we should be mature enough to
actually
ha you know just to think about things
process the emotions ourself and move on
to the next game
but i've actually been really impressed
with ivanka today because twice she's
been saying that she's enjoying this
bishop or really playing with this piece
i don't play with pizza i just suffer
pieces
maybe that's my problem everything feels
like it's
bound to fall down and go bad at some
point whereas i i really wish i could
approach that part where you see like oh
my this piece is so strong i'm just
gonna use this for ellsworth yeah but
the thing is though i am an observer
here i am a spectator i can sit there
and watch the games and we all can enjoy
it and we can throw the pieces away
we're like hey why didn't he sacrifice
this why doesn't do that but the reality
is when you're sat there over the board
i think it's true i think they're saying
about age we talk about age earlier and
it's um i think when you're young you
have no fear right so you look at
position you're like you're very
optimistic about it but as you get older
it's like oh hang on a minute i'm
worried about this worried about that
and you're more worried about things as
you get older so you're not quite as
confident as you as you get older i i
think that's kind of a natural
development i think you definitely take
defeats harder take it more personally
when you're older you think i've spent
half my life studying for this one game
and or building up to this one game and
it all went wrong what's wrong with me
we're making it sound so great aren't we
you know but it's beautiful it's
beautiful when you win and uh
okay meanwhile a few moves have happened
as predicted black's queen did come out
to the g file white has tried to
kind of plug the line towards the white
king with a knight and now okay eric's
taking the time out as well to improve
the white rook as we indicated a few
moves ago and uh yeah if we jump in just
to show i think a very easy natural com
kind of continuation for black there's
two moves that i want to play both
involve getting this knight into this
glorious f4 square one is to jump in
first
uh viewers at home might ask why not
just jump in to attack the queen also
some threats towards the white king side
maybe but this knight can be eliminated
and it's just about whether the two
bishops here are superior to the two
white knights here i think they are but
you do lose a lot of flexibility without
your own knight without the black knight
being attacking piece and that's why
actually if we just rewind after bishop
takes bishop which was played suddenly
the black knight jumps in now so you
don't have the bishop player any longer
but you have this fearsome attacking
knight and
we know what's coming at some point yeah
this pawn at some point is going to
destabilize white tonight kick it away
for example if white is too slow then
this pawn will push forward and
immediately is winning because uh yes
the white knight can jump back but
there's going to be attacks on this
square and for example the white the
black knight now can come and check win
this uh win the spawn hitting the white
king because uh it can't be captured due
to a pin along the g file so eric in the
current position
whoa he's just put his queen on this
square i was about to say he needs to
gain time give a check maybe um at least
force black's king away
and gain a move with which to defend but
instead he's put his queen on a
different square he's put his queen on
this square on f3 but
what is it doing here it's just a target
for black's rook but also a target for
black's bishop
i don't really understand i must confess
at the very least black and maybe even
take this pawn at some point
i think he was slightly worried about
maybe
knight takes porn uh moves i'm thinking
of the pawn on g2 actually okay and uh
he just wanted to avoid that so that's
why he put his queen on this ugly square
but you're right there's like something
in the air this is where um chessable
author and grandma say yasser sarawan
goes oh my spidey senses are tingling
yeah
if you have a one of your own pieces
especially a queen stared down at by an
opponent's rook it's never going to end
well and okay the pawn push did happen
as simon indicated this knight was
kicked back and
there's going to be a trick at some
point the white queen is going to drop
to the black rook i just feel it and uh
and i even don't understand that last
move
but maybe had to play that that's the
problem because uh otherwise you'd lose
the exchange but white's pieces are
getting kicked too
under squares i mean
no future that night now
yeah so at the very least black can just
take this pawn and bring another piece
into the attack if he wants to build up
you can just move his rook forward
bring his other rook across double
things up against the white queen it's
just glorious you can win this position
quickly you can win it slowly maybe
maybe you can bring your bishop to life
with a d5 push in the middle explain
things open just get that bishop
pointing towards the king as well
there's so many good moves right i love
having krishna's move and um yeah just
as i was trying to get in his mind and
uh yeah he would never dream of taking a
pawn he would never dream of allowing
his own point to drop because he is
obsessed with control harry krishna
that's his chest style and therefore he
moves his pawn up one square and he
wants to bring his other rook across now
we'll control i'm surprised the
evaluation was down to under minus one
because it looks like black is
completely utterly winning now
and uh okay white push the pawn forward
and the black rook is going to join it's
com uh join its buddy
incidentally you know i i just saw an um
an article actually from chesapeal
author alex kolovich and he was talking
about this type of rook defensive move
and uh he kind of said it was in the
style of kappa blanca the way that kappa
blanca played those endings you know
instead of
instead of allowing his opponent any
form of counter play he's just like no
control the position first and then
continue with his plans
it's just good chess
controlling squares stopping the
opponent's ideas
yeah um all the black pieces just look
so well placed there and there's nothing
i can't see anything immediate so you
might still have to bring in another
piece that's why i want to do the
central break
just bring the last piece into the game
the bishop in the corner
where's white soap here
that's a good question i think actually
whites move at some point not right now
is to just move the white queen across
one square and offer a trade of queens
on the g file if the white queen if the
two coins disappear some chances to save
the game so i think he's gonna hope that
he can survive to the end game eric this
middle game is ugly so uh it's all about
surviving till the end game
if he does survive if the quiz do come
off then maybe the momentum will change
maybe we'll see the trend
uh switch around
harry krishna will be kicking himself
actually if he doesn't convert or if he
doesn't gain a kind of decisive
advantage in the next five six moves
harry krishna might get frustrated
but with a 0.8 evaluation there is a way
right
um yeah i i don't know if there's
anything immediate though i mean it is
strange because it looks visually so
good because all the black's pieces are
sort of in the right squares but i i
can't there's no like crash band wallop
and say like you know way to break
through that i can see here so you've
got it you still you still got to win
this position
the one thing that's worrying for me i
think maybe that's influencing and maybe
um kind of pushing my judgment even
further in black's direction is that
eric just for about one minute there or
half a minute he was just looking away
head in his hands he wasn't even looking
at the board
i think if he were now he's refocusing
but if he does kind of calm himself down
and kind of forget about the last game
forget about the opening in this game
then he'll realize he's still alive and
uh okay eric just about to make a move
but if we show maybe what he could try
for example if he tries to swap off
queens now this is a mistake he tries to
trade queens because after a queen trade
there's a night fork hitting the two
rooks so i think he has to prepare this
i think he has to move one of his rooks
out of the way not sure exactly where
but for example one of his rooks lifting
it up and next move preparing to trade
queens and uh it's still going to be a
difficult end game difficult defense
ahead but he just has to
look on the bright side if the queen's
come off he's still alive
yeah i guess you have to play some uh
rook move to to defend um
maybe you can prepare that idea um by
okay do we have a move okay by playing
the move you you play david or pushing
it one square even further forwards but
something sensible and defensive
is not eric's style though
he you know he doesn't like going on the
back foot if he but he has to
and like you said there's ideas like
pushing the pawn forward breaking open
this bishop breaking it out of jail and
i mean it's on such a good diagonal if
things open up um also actually just
looking at it maybe black can even get
flashy here simon and play queen takes
pawn giving away a knight temporarily
sacrificing a knight but at the very end
of this variation there's rook takes
pawn and checking the way
nice tactics i i miss those things yeah
yeah i'm not very well to see that one
but i think that's the direct threat in
the position so this eric has to tread
very cautiously actually if he wants to
play this queen trade i idea then he has
to
step forward with his rook one square
yeah yeah but it's i mean it's such a
hard move to play and there's downsides
to that as well three minutes left as
well he's he's not comfortable that's
probably
no
and i think it's harder because eric
isn't a full-time player he streams he
does other stuff
and he mentioned it last month right i
think to use for
just the opening preparation
he's just not there he doesn't have a
big team around him doesn't have the
same time resources
he doesn't really focus at it at all he
he was saying how it's so hard to know
when the invitations are going to come
and he loves the ability to play here in
the meltwater championship tour but it's
it's hard to put together a team if
you're living in complete uncertainty
and i can understand that i mean he's he
has created a whole new uh
entrepreneurship and business ship that
it that does take a lot of time and i
can see how getting back into those
eight to ten hours per day of hard work
that that's tough
yes
and it's also hard to balance it because
as we know as we just discussed chess
can be quite painful you know if you're
not winning things not going your way
it's actually can be not very enjoyable
you know winning is enjoyable when
you're at his level and uh he's got a
career streaming you know uh easier
career he's very popular he's very good
at it and that's that's kind of like i'm
not going to say the easy option but
maybe the more fun option as well so
it's like uh you kind of have to
dedicate um to being a chess player to
compete with these guys definitely yeah
you also kind of need a team around you
to take care of all the
mundane stuff and like i know eric
recently
moved from i don't know where he was but
he moved to toronto and you know that
again takes up energy you have to sort
out your equipment you have to sort out
basic things and it takes time and it's
nhl team calgary flames lost last night
in the in the standing club playoffs and
i know that hits eric more than it does
most people
and that's actually no joke that
actually matters to you yeah chess plays
are superstitious so if your favorite
sports team loses you have a feeling it
might not be a good day or you could
have been out commiserating as well you
know if that probably uh
doesn't help so do you think that i was
just gonna say here he comes you know i
was going to say well now that the night
has come backwards such a natural fine
it's time to go forwards literally if
you look at every single one of the
black pieces they point towards the
white king
black queen points towards the white
king the black knight is super close uh
the black bishop's on the diagonal the
black rooks pointing down towards the
white king
it must be a miracle if white saves this
i mean there's got to be a killer blow
now surely i mean you know you can just
take the pawn if you want to go porn up
but
um
it looks like you know there's something
here yeah i mean everything's now
working for black i'm trying to look but
you're right simon worst comes to the
west you have the backup option of just
taking white central pawn for free with
your own pawn yeah one point up and with
the attack
long term that should be winning uh
maybe there's something else to do with
the night jump right now
yeah i think you should just uh capture
that pawn
it's uh for free out for grabs like you
say and also the great thing if you
capture that pawn you actually secure
some squares for your knight
yeah so if we jump in and actually that
has just happened so in the current
position the queen was attacked finally
eric is offering this trade of queens
but i don't think harry christian is
going to oblige him and say yes i think
harold christian is going to run away
there's plenty of squares i'm not sure
the best one for black i would be
tempted to actually swing the whole way
across just to kind of stare down at the
white king on this diagonal but no
matter where you go i really want to
make e3 e3 work here as well you know
just because in this position pushing
apart i don't i don't think it really
achieves much but i just want to get the
bishop in the game and if you go queen
takes queen there's a nice little idea
of pawn takes pawn check or something or
what about this one check i like that
maybe
this one's a checkmate with a pawn oh
yes that is pure porn
that is checkmating with a pawn that's
obviously what i meant by that um
checking the king and then look at this
bishop cutting off the escape squares
yeah that is that's that is sexy that is
lovely so yeah very nice stuff but
that's going to be my new expression go
to expression that is pure part
it's a pure porn tech check mate i don't
know what you're thinking there but uh
you know it's just a it's a pawn check
mate you didn't go for it unfortunately
i mean i don't think it was the best
move uh white would have had options to
defend but now as sievenko mentioned
this square is beautiful for the black
knight it's a nice outpost in white's
camp it's what we call an octopus an
octo knight with its uh tentacles
everywhere and uh this would be winning
another option for black would be to
lift his rook up maybe one square swing
it across and go for white's queen
white's king
he chooses the most natural option this
black knight dominates the two white
rooks and
i think we're in the closing stages of
this game now black's piece is just too
strong
yeah i think so there's nothing to be
done here is there so at least eric has
temporarily blocked out that black
bishop that black bishop is only staring
down at its own pawns but
i mean the white knights i mean
especially that white knight on the edge
of the board on h2 does not make a great
impression and eric
yeah he was uh kind of slapping himself
slightly there he's yeah i mean he knows
that this is
going to be another loss unfortunately
and in a way he kind of lost it himself
he didn't recover and it was a bad
opening
and it all came down to that last game
the previous round
[Music]
he's done nothing wrong played very
smoothly just slowly improved his pieces
and i think that's a good tip for
players of all levels if in doubt no
matter what your opponent is doing just
just slowly improve your pieces
especially if you feel a bit of weakness
from them a bit of impatience and what
do you think about eric's last move you
know he's just said fine take the rook
but i'm gonna push harry one square you
know when in doubt push harry but uh i
don't quite see what he's trying to do
other other than uh
me neither i i didn't get it block up
the dark squares i guess i mean i i
think black can take on f2 next move as
well i mean if he wants to i mean the
rooks are coming in black rooks i mean
every move is pretty bad so it's uh yeah
right now black is up a rook and a pawn
just for one night so that's a decisive
material advantage but also you have the
attack
yeah black rooks coming in maybe i know
it's just a saying here you've won i'm
just curious that whole when in doubt
push harry has that become more true
after that whole alpha zero thing going
on and how the h pawn is just turning
into a monster yeah has it always been
true no it happened it's been singing
for 20 years
is the pioneer here he has been
advocating harry for a long time
um so it's him and alpha zero pretty
much yeah the thing is though you know
drunk alpha zero
well the thing machine was like simon
was okay so we do see the rook takes
born simon you know he was advocating it
quite strongly but people were kind of
like mixed minds it's like yeah yeah
that's fine for you simon you have an
aggressive style it's very intuitive but
not for me thank you very much and
suddenly when the alpha zero started
doing it it became like oh hang on a
second here
if
alpha zero is doing it then maybe we can
do it too and uh yeah and it just
revolutionized that i think it's amazing
though how a computer
changed how humans think so much how
this program
literally changed how humans over how
many you know hundreds of years of
thinking about chess changed it in like
a space of a week changed their thinking
about chess and that that is incredible
really to think about that how how not
that many games even yeah i mean just uh
you know just alpha zero just played you
know it was a course of a week or so
wasn't it and
it changed humor's perspective from the
game which is you know
martially revolutionized so many top
players games yeah i mean everyone was
going down the same openings the same
drawish lines suddenly no we can push
our rook spawns it's yeah in every
single position uh go on the attack in
weird wonderful positions sacrifice
material which computers never ever did
before really yeah and uh yeah it's uh
but it must have been also great for
especially you guys you you spent so
much your life with says you've you
worked so much on chess to see
that computers doesn't necessarily have
to be a limiting factor it could
actually be expensive and actually
broaden the game as a whole
yeah i think that's probably life
nowadays in general i mean rather than
acting against computers we we've got to
act with them and in nearly anything we
do like
again poker is the same as i mean like
but in work situations you've got to try
to use them as an ally rather than sort
of an enemy i think and it's especially
true in chess
but it's nice because it was always the
topic can computers have emotion can
they be creative that was something
which was uh very fiercely debated like
uh going back 20 years but now it's kind
of shown that they can be creative and
they can do creative things that humans
can't do which is which is you know a
big change i think in civilization as
well really yeah just as you're talking
simon harry christian is down to 30
seconds now which is very surprising his
position is so winning uh all he needs
to do is trade queens for example uh
which i think he can do by force um
white's knights are not that great right
now but is harry krishna getting nervous
okay up to one minute maybe there was a
bit of delay there but uh either way
maybe some chances for eric
okay the white knights at least
defending each other getting coordinated
have we written him off too soon harry
krishna i think out of all the top guys
maybe he's one of the least comfortable
um kind of playing when he's under one
minute under 30 seconds
um over the board when i've played him a
few times he does slightly panic
because his instinct is to keep control
and in rapid chess when you're low on
time
in a kind of imbalanced position like
this sometimes you can't always take
keep control like simon says you have to
kind of finish things off you have to
calculate a bit you have to take a small
risk sometimes to win the games well
he's playing in a very materialistic
fashion though you know he's put his
rook on the third row maybe going for
the a pawn
and
you know he's kind of saying yes white
you have a fantastic queen
in the middle of the board but you know
if you move it away like eric hanson's
done you comes with consequences and now
the black queen can also mobilize
attacking harry the h-porn that famous
pawn yeah there's a big chicken
there i'm not sure how white can defend
actually here now i mean like queen has
to drop back well but then there's a
tactic i i is there a tactic there maybe
uh
yeah maybe we can show this big big
threat on the board um eric ticking down
to about one minute but the big threat
is the queen coming down to this square
backed up supported by her rook uh for
example if white just plays too slowly
the queen's coming down check hitting
the king picking up the white rook on
the next turn and um as the evangel
mentions i think
strictly the only way to defend against
this threat this check is to bring back
white's queen you also defend this pawn
in the process but now all of the white
pieces are just purely defensive did you
know what i thought black could play
here i thought i thought black could
play rook takes f1 check which doesn't
work for so many reasons it's not even a
good move i don't know if it's not even
attacking i know i know but that's also
a problem so it was like wow that's
that's uh that time of day
the problem is that every single
peaceful white the knight this knight
the rogue queen they're all purely
defensive and you're down on material so
black can take his time black and just
grab this pawn black and bring the
bishop into place slowly um simon you
mentioned eventually you want to remove
this defender uh it takes a while but
hey eric lifting his rook up the board
instead if we go to the current position
and
yeah at the very least black can just
take off harry the h pawn and
be materialistic here
it's very very winning at this point
just about the clock maybe just move the
rook down to pin pinning and winning
could be the end of the game that would
be brutal the black rook coming down
pinning and if the white knight takes
this rook you actually win both of the
black both of the white knights now in
one swoop you play queen takes knight
check and he's done it he's about to win
both white knights and he's going to
emerge with an extra bishop for free
and with the attack so yeah this one is
going to be game over any moment
harry krishna about to be a clear piece
up
is there any maybe any
queen
the queen can come and give a check so
eric has tried that okay the king moves
away
you can even block it with a bishop yeah
like you say i mean you're just moving
the king if you're short time is
probably the move to play uh if you
can't calculate blocking with a bishop
but this bishop block is very effective
if the white knight takes this bishop
then queen uh okay queen takes knight
check and we're about to see a result
this will end in checkmate uh the white
king is not going to escape from
attack
that
this
yeah
yeah eric resigns and that that shows